eight billion people on earth by
november that's the forecast from the
united nations but global population
growth is slowing down and many
societies are also getting older so how
do we deal with the challenges ahead
this is inside story
[Music]
hello there and welcome to the program
i'm nastasia tay now the world's
population is growing but at its slowest
pace in 70 years that's the conclusion
of the un's latest global population
forecast we are generally living longer
and healthier lives than previous
generations but this the report also
says will have huge implications for our
economy social welfare systems and our
environment now the number of people on
our planet is expected to hit 8 billion
by november and then increase by half a
billion towards the end of this decade
but birth rates meanwhile are falling in
many countries in the coming years
global population growth will be
concentrated in just eight nations
democratic republic of congo egypt
ethiopia nigeria pakistan the
philippines tanzania and india which is
expected to surpass china as the most
populous nation on the planet next year
the global population is also getting
older on average a person is expected to
live to 77 years by 2050. that's up from
73 and 2019.
well the director of the united nations
population division explains the effects
of aging societies worldwide
traditionally we had many more children
than older people to take care of uh
and and now it's
switching to a point where you know
depending on how you define the age
groups
the number of older people will
eventually be larger than the number of
children
uh and
this you know this has implications for
rather obvious reasons that you've got a
lot of private and public arrangements
to care for people at older ages
there are financial implications
involved especially for government
budgets
but there are also real concerns about
you know the living conditions for those
elderly people what will that be like
and will the will there be adequate
social protections to ensure that uh
this growing population of older people
uh is not impoverished
well we'll bring in all of our guests in
just a moment but first this report from
pavnei mittal in new delhi
next year india is set to surpass china
and the gap between these two nations
could increase by 2050
this could help india in many ways for
example india has been pushing for more
representation internationally experts
say that concerns and demands could
carry more weight especially at forums
like the united nations on the economic
front this makes india the world's
largest consumer market one that could
invite a lot more investment now
domestically population control has been
a contentious electoral issue
experts have advocated for more focus on
reproductive rights and justice this
includes improving girls education
increasing the number of women in the
workforce and improving maternal health
some of these efforts have been
effective because the rate of population
growth has slowed down considerably but
there are many challenges the pandemic
has reversed many of these gains many
women have been forced to quit the
workforce and there has been an increase
in child marriages experts say there
needs to be more awareness so family
planning becomes an issue of choice and
not chance and coercion
well there's obviously plenty to take
apart from this report but i do want to
start with where we are at the moment
we're obviously living in a pandemic and
i believe the report suggests 15 million
excess deaths just to the end of 2021 a
fall in life expectancy but that all
seems to be a bit of a blip given the
trends that we're looking at so we're
mostly living longer but reproducing
less
daryl you wrote a book called empty
planet just a couple of years back do
you still think that that's the way
we're headed yeah and even faster than
we were talking about in the book
and really that the focus of all of this
we can talk about the pandemic we can
talk about aging we can talk about those
kinds of things but the real uh
pot point in the un's analysis is
fertility
and that's really what uh empty planet
is about and so what's happening to
fertility rates well they're collapsing
well with the medium fertility scenario
i believe the un is projecting that
global population will peak before the
end of this century so
2086 at just over 10.4 billion people
kathleen i believe you were very much
involved with the last u.n report on the
world's population so this projection is
obviously as daryl said sooner than the
last projection what's driving that
change
well my understanding is that the global
population projections are
put together every two to three years
from a number of different national
censuses and they haven't the long-range
projections have not changed too much
over the years
right now we're at a world population of
about 7.9 billion
the medium projection as you as you
mentioned by 2100 we could be at 10.4
billion but there's also a very wide
range there's a lot of uncertainty about
population trends moving into the future
and it has a lot to do with the kinds of
policies and programs that are in place
in countries all over the world so the
un has projected that the range of
possible population futures by 2100 are
from a low of 7 billion to a high of
14.8 billion that is a very wide range
of possibility for how population could
grow in the future and i would argue
that that has significant implications
for the health and well-being of people
and for the health and well-being of the
planet we'll get into some of those
trends in just a moment but i want to
look at
the growth that we're seeing on the
horizon the immediate horizon eight
billion people on this planet by
november give or take a year um
according to the report and much of that
growth is going to be taking place in
india so poonam i was looking at the
number of births per woman there and it
actually seems to have dropped so what's
driving population growth there
so um there are a number of factors the
first is that
education which as we all know is the
best contraceptive
but girls are getting
higher education levels are
taking place second i believe the
government has invested
in family planning with a focus in the
high fertility districts in india see in
india it's a very uneven situation where
much of south india
has reached uh replacement level
fertility in fact 24 states in india
and the six states in north india which
had high fertility rates the rates are
coming down because the government uh
through its new programming is focusing
in these high fertility districts third
there's greater access to
larger number of contraceptives you know
every time a new contraceptive is
introduced uh there is a six to twelve
percent increase globally or within any
country where it is increased
uh contraceptives are introduced new
contraceptives some modern contraceptive
methods have been introduced and lastly
i'd like to say um that the we had a
much higher fertility rate let's say
amongst muslims earlier but the muslim
fertility rate has declined very sharply
in the last two decades especially in
the last decade and a growing middle
class as well as the fact that people
value education for girls more than they
used to is what is
helping and finally
age at marriage is increasing which also
helps with fertility decline as well as
postponement of the first child and
spacing method uh poonam despite all of
that though we are still expecting india
to overtake china as the world's most
populated um the most the world's most
populated country by potentially next
year and i see that's already beginning
to spur talk of a permanent seat on the
u.n security council now given the
trends that we're seeing and where this
population growth is taking place uh
daryl let me ask you what kind of
political shifts should we be looking
for well i think we should be
increasingly looking for uh population
power to drive political power and uh
what we haven't brought up here is the
only continent that in the world in
which there is growth significant growth
uh going long term longer term into the
future and that's africa
because that's really the only
continent or i guess region depending on
how you want to define it that really
has still above replacement rate
population both china i mean the three
world's largest three countries china
india and uh in the united states all
recorded historic lows
last year over the last couple of years
for their fertility rates so they're not
going to be challenging for global
population dominance the way they were
in the past increasingly it's going to
be a focus on africa i want to get into
africa in a moment but because of puna
i'm talking about reproductive rights i
want to also bring in at this point the
u.n secretary general's response to the
population forecast that we saw antonio
guterres says it's an occasion to
celebrate the health achievements that
have extended life spans and reduce
child mortality worldwide but he did
also criticize what he called renewed
assaults on a woman's right to access
health services and to make informed
choices on whether or not to even have a
baby complications from pregnancy and
childbirth are among the leading causes
of death for girls between the ages of
15 to 19.
parts of africa and south asia account
for 86 of maternal deaths worldwide and
last month the us supreme court
overturned roe versus wade a landmark
ruling that guaranteed abortion rights
meanwhile poland has also restricted
access to the procedure there's
obviously vast inequity when it comes to
reproductive rights kathleen how does
that then translate into broader
patterns of inequity
i think one of the most fascinating
things to think about and to look at
when we're when we're examining
population trends is to understand what
they tell us about persistent inequities
across society whether that's inequities
in reproductive rights and reproductive
access to reproductive health care which
is still a huge problem for many
people for young women and girls around
the world who would like to be able to
delay pregnancy or avoid pregnancy but
don't have access to meaningful
information and services that would
enable them to achieve reproductive
autonomy this is a very basic
fundamental human right for reproductive
autonomy that hundreds of millions of
people around the world still do not
have
um it also tells us a lot about gender
inequity and the ways in which girls
hundreds of millions of girls are not
able to go to school
the ways in which women do not have are
not empowered in the workforce or in the
household to be able to really realize
opportunities in their lives that
include motherhood but extend beyond
motherhood so a lot of what is driving
persistent rapid population growth which
as our other guest says is happening in
africa but also in pockets all across
the world
is this indication of a lack of rights
in inequities especially in the health
and gender spaces well let's turn to
africa now because looking at the
numbers more than half of the growth
we're expecting by 2050 is going to come
from africa by which time i believe
nigeria is set to become the fourth most
populous country on the planet we're
looking at decreasing reproduction rates
around the world as people get richer
but i know there are also some experts
who argue that africa's rate of decrease
is actually less or slower than perhaps
some other parts of the developing world
because culturally the ideal family size
is larger than elsewhere daryl what do
you make of that
well i think the first thing and the un
recognizes this in their report the data
from africa aren't great so we're we
don't really know precisely what's going
on in africa but uh you know if if the
past is prologue
i expect that the trends that we see in
other parts of the world that you know
are moved incredibly rapidly in terms of
changing their fertility rates mainly as
a result of culture that the effect of
that is going to be significant in
africa too
we're just having a pretty difficult
time measuring it but in places where we
do have better data say for example at
like kenya where they do have good
population data you look at the
the fertility rate in a place like
nairobi and it's pretty close to
replacement rate so the trends that are
happening everywhere else in the world
are also going to be happening in africa
we just don't know how fast because it's
really hard to get a handle on what's
going on for example in nigeria sure
well some of the demographics in africa
the ones that we do have are also really
interesting in nigeria i believe 70
percent of its 200 million people right
now are currently under 30. so the
population growth that we're seeing
there is also a rise in the working age
population this so-called demographic
dividend that could either be an
opportunity for economic growth or
potentially a cause for political strife
poonam how have you seen that be played
out in india
so in india
the main reason fertility will grow is
because we have 360 million
young people
many of who are at a reproductive health
age or will reach there very soon
but in india we keep talking about the
demographic dividend because we have a
large
youth population but the problem is that
the window is small it is not a
permanent feature so the window for
harvesting the demographic dividend is
close to 15 years more in
at an average some states
a little longer
we have to invest in young people's
education but more than that also jobs
for the demographic dividend to take
place and become a reality we have to
invest in jobs and at this point of time
there is
huge number of young people who are not
skilled to even take advantage of the
job opportunities that do exist so if we
don't do something very quickly in terms
of skill
training skill development and getting
jobs uh for young people we are going to
have a demographic disaster so right now
we are on a high
and we have an opportunity and i must
say that there is a realization earlier
we thought it is very automatic that the
demographic dividend will happen so in
india we are um
a vibrance killing and so on we also
need to have more temporary methods and
access greater access for young people
to contraception and finally sex
education and especially information on
reproductive
not just
rights and justice we also need access
to family planning services and
temporary methods
india focuses primarily on sterilization
which is a permanent method while young
people need access to temporary methods
and they don't plan families they need
access to contraception so the earlier
india begins to recognize
and
bring in um in schools out of schools
greater information on uh and
comprehensive sexuality education will
do better but skills is something we are
aware but india's grappling with and i'm
grateful
bring in kathleen here because i see you
nodding and agreeing with much of that
kathleen but do you see this demographic
dividend as a potential threat or only
an opportunity
well one of the things that's really
critical to understand about the
demographic dividend is that it is
realized when there is a decline in
fertility that is the thing that
triggers a demographic dividend so that
the proportion of the population that is
in the working age is larger
and as punam mentioned it is a brief
period of time
it requires this decline in fertility it
also requires uh investments in
education and
employment opportunities for that brief
period of time that we have this really
large age large cohort of the population
in the working age so it's it's not
simply the demographic dividend does not
come simply from rapid population growth
it's rapid population growth followed by
a period of fertility decline that
results in this big chunk of the
population in the working age
realm and that is really difficult to
accomplish but there are a lot of
opportunities for it but it does require
lots of investment in
contraceptive options as poonam was
mentioning in sexuality education and
things that advance gender equity in
access to reproductive health care in a
wide range of contraceptive methods and
then also the the plethora of education
and employment opportunities that need
to be ready for this very large cohort
that is coming into the working age for
relation but that surely also has some
political implications i'll bring daryl
in here what do you make of where this
could shift things particularly for the
developing world
well actually i think the the really
interesting thing for me in listening to
this conversation is how much this
conversation is going to change over the
next 10 to 15 years
because the conversation is going to
shift from this kind of 1970s you know
overpopulation population bomb type of
of of of a discourse over to one in in
particularly in the developed world
where this is going to get very
controversial about how do we promote
having children
because we've got many countries now and
un identified them in the report i think
it was 61. they're now actually
experiencing population decline
countries like like italy for example
they're losing 50 000 people a year from
their population japan loses about half
a million people from their population
every year
spain loses about 50 000 people from
their population every year and we have
a whole series of countries in places
like eastern europe in which the the
numbers are even more shocking
so what we're going to start seeing is a
shift in the conversation i think
in in away from just meeting the
challenges of the developing world to
start talking about what we're going to
do in terms of population management in
countries that are really going to be
challenged by aging and shrinking
populations
by 2030 the entire global baby boom is
going to be 65 years of age or older
we're not ready for that well let's talk
about this aging population then how's
that been playing out in india because
we're talking about a broader population
of older people living longer that has
resource
resource implications of its
own yeah that is actually something
that's very worrying for those of us who
work on population issues because india
does not have any social security
whether it is health or its
[Music]
financial so we are worried about the
aging population but there isn't much
work being done
in india it's only actually after the
last report of the u.n that there was
even conversation beginning about aging
and in india where
a large percentage of people there's
huge migration
from the villages there is very little
security in terms of caregiving also for
the agent and i india has to prepare
itself for
making uh
universal health coverage a reality for
across india we have to strengthen our
public health systems we have to
reimagine uh our public health systems
which we recognize during coverage
finally that being it is our public
health is an icu thirdly i think
financial investment
for um
a
fiscal support and so on to
the aged population is something that
india will have to plan for and invest
in
um i'm sorry i i want to at this point
sorry turn to the environment because i
don't want us to run out of time before
getting there and we're talking really
about constraints on resources here and
obviously a huge one is
what we're going to see in terms of
climate change impacts a lot of this
population growth is going to be taking
place in climate vulnerable areas i mean
at the very simplest level more people
on the planet means more strain on
resources we're already seeing concerns
around food security kathleen are you
worried about the population trends
we're seeing
i i'm very worried about it and i i want
to disagree with with daryl a little bit
about
what which of the population trends we
need to be most concerned about
certainly an aging population is
something that we need to plan for
prepare for and have um adequate social
security systems in place to to manage
an aging population and to think about
how we adequately employ a smaller
workforce smaller proportion of
population workforce in some places but
i really think that the larger problem
is that the population is still growing
globally from around 8 billion today and
it could be up to 14 billion by the end
of the century hopefully it won't be
there but it depends a lot on what we
invest in okay i will bring in daryl
here because we are talking about this
peak and decline
um and this is going to happen literally
within the next hundred years so
obviously a debate about whether that's
a good thing uh daryl go for it
well look any estimate that says it can
be between eight and fourteen million is
why don't we make it seven and fourteen
million is a hundred percent variation
that's not really much of an estimate
uh and really when you take a look at
the more compelling evidence about
what's happening hold on a second
i let you talk let me talk
if you take a look at the work that uh
the bill and melinda gates foundation
published in the lancet that was done by
a whole global series of demographers
and it was done pre-covet
they don't even come close to that
number
i mean so i i really have a lot of
questions about how the un does its
modeling i think this whole population
momentum uh you know theory is just that
a theory i think there's a lot of
cultural change that's taking place
around all of these things that are
actually going to cause fertility
decline to accelerate
the population increase is not going to
get even close to 10.4 million people
we're going to be
probably somewhere between eight and
nine billion people which is not much
far off further off of where we are
today but it's going to be a very
different mix of people they're going to
be highly urbanized and they're going to
be much much older than the population
we have on the face of europe today
that's the challenge we're truly facing
both challenges and opportunities well
we'll have to leave our discussion there
for today but we'll be keeping an eye on
how this all plays out over the coming
decades and centuries um thank you to
all of our guests that's kathleen
moglegard daryl bricker and poonam
mutraja and thank you to for watching
you can see this program again anytime
by visiting our website aljazeera.com
and for further discussion do go to our
facebook page that's facebook.com
forward slash aj inside story and
remember you can also join the
conversation on twitter our handle is at
aj inside story from me anastasia tay
and the whole team here in doha bye for
now
[Music]